翻訳: Reiko Bovee
校正: Mari Arimitsu
皆さんは 日本における高齢化推移が
どうなっているかご存知でしょうか
これは内閣府がまとめた
高齢社会白書のグラフになります
2015年現在 日本の総人口は
ピークを迎えつつあります
今後 世の中で言われているように
少子化が進み 年々年を追う毎に
日本の総人口は
減少[の一途]を辿って行きます
そして40年後 2055年には
65才以上の高齢者が占める割合が
全日本人口の約40%を占めるまでに
増えてしまいます
つまり 今我々の世代が40年後 まさに
この高齢者という所に居ることになります
一方 第１次産業と呼ばれる
農林水産業の分野に従事している人の数は
どうなっているか
皆さんご存知でしょうか
高齢化しているにも拘らず
第１次産業に従事する人の数は
年々低下の一途を辿っています
全産業に占める第１次産業の割合は
なんと3.6%しかないという少なさが
今の状況だと言えます
このような状況で
第１次産業 農林水産業というものは
日本から無くなってしまうのでしょうか
こちらは農林水産省のまとめた
「生産農業所得統計」というグラフです
上に示させて頂きましたのは
農業が生み出すお金
「農業総産出額」のグラフとなります
農業従事者の数が減少しているのもあり
農業が総出する農業総産出額というのも
年々減少しています
そのため農業に従事している
農業従事者の所得 生産農業所得というのも
年々低下の一途を辿っている
ということが分かると思います
過酷な農作業 収入も不安定かもしれない
このようなイメージの強い農業を
堅実な道を歩もうとする若者は
あえて選ぼうとするでしょうか
そのため高齢化の進行は増々進み
農業従事者は減少 耕作放棄地も増加
こういった悪循環が 今の日本の状況を
表しているのではないかと感じます
では 日本の第１次産業の将来は
本当に悲観すべきことばかりだと思いますか
私はそんなことはないと感じています
現在 私どもの世代は
農業に従事しておりませんが
企業戦士として夜遅くまで日夜 仕事に
明け暮れているという事実があります
そして自然に触れながら 自分のペースと
裁量で仕事ができる農業というものに
ある意味で あこがれを抱いている
そういう人もいるかも知れません
また情報通信技術を駆使して
生産方法の工夫や改善をすることで
収穫規模や収益性を
拡大できるのではないか
そういう可能性を感じたりします
第１次産業が生産する特産物を
第２次産業によって
高い付加価値をつけ
ブランド化を進め
そして第３次産業の流通と販売に
効果的に結びつけることができれば
１x２x３が６になるように
第６次産業化
つまり農業の総産業化というものが
実現できるのではないかと考えています
もちろんここには 食品衛生や
リスク管理への責任といった問題が
発生することはあります
ただし超高齢化社会を
迎えるという実情に対し
あまり悲観的なことばかり
考えてばかりいるわけにもいかないのかな
というのが正直なところです
皆さんは日本の「植物工場」
という技術をご存知でしょうか
この中でも植物工場という技術に
関与されている方が
少なからずいるかもしれません
Googleの画像検索で「植物工場」
というキーワードで検索すると
このような結果が得られます
植物工場には大きく分けて
２つの種類があって
太陽光を利用した
「太陽光利用型植物工場」というものと
LEDや蛍光灯を利用して
工場のような形で生産する
「人工光利用型植物工場」
というものがあります
実際に大手機械メーカー等は
LEDや蛍光灯を用い
工場のクリーンルームのような所を
改造することによって
レタスや葉物の植物
そう言ったものを
生産し販売する
という事業を始めています
つまり 先程ご紹介したような
農業の総産業化―
６次産業化というものは
着々と進んでいるという事実がうかがえます
では世界はどうでしょうか
これはコロンビア大学の
ディクソン・デポミエ教授が提唱する
「バーティカル・ファーム」という
コンセプトになります
日本語に訳すと「垂直農業」
という風に翻訳することが出来ます
このコンセプトは都市圏の
土地の有効活用の
一案として提案されています
このような１つの建物の中で
家畜を育てるだけでなく
植物を育て 葉物だけでなく
果物まで育てる
そして そこで生産された野菜や肉を
１階のスーパーで販売するという
建物を縦に 循環型の農業を
実現してしまおうという構想です
もし このような都市部で
垂直農業というものが実現できたとしたら
輸送費の大幅な削減ができるだけでなく
新たな雇用創出 生活との調和
明るい未来が
創造できるのではないかと感じます
もちろん こんな世界を実現するには
経済的な問題 エネルギー消費効率の問題
様々な課題があります
ですが このコンセプトを元に
デザイナーの方々が描いた
この絵を見させて頂くと
私も頭の片隅に こんな世界が
いつか本当に作ることができないのか
ということを想像しながら 日夜
研究に明け暮れているという状況です
では ここから私の研究の話に
入りたいと思います
皆さんは植物の成長が
どのような仕組みによって
行われているか覚えていますか
実は これは小学校４年生の
理科の教科書に載っています
植物は葉の表で光合成を行い
葉の裏で蒸散を行って成長して行きます
光合成というのは
太陽の光エネルギーを用いて
大気中のCO2と根から吸収した水から
有機物を合成する仕組みです
一方 日が当たり始めると
葉の裏からは 蒸散が始まって
根から水や養分を吸収し
植物の全体に輸送が始まります
では この植物の成長を測るには
どうしたらいいでしょうか
植物の成長を測ることが出来れば
植物の生育状態を
コントロールできるかも知れません
私はこの素朴な疑問に対し
植物の成長は光合成と蒸散に関係する
光合成と蒸散は 植物の葉っぱに
含まれる成分によって行われる
ということは植物の葉が
どれ位茂っているのか ということを
間接的にでも計測することが出来れば
植物の成長を測ることが
できるのではないかと考えました
そして 今日ここで持って来た物が
そのために研究開発した物になります
こちらは無線で計測できる
「無線散乱光センサ」とよばれる物です
植物の成長は光合成と蒸散
つまり葉っぱが どれだけ茂っているか
ということに関係があります
葉っぱは茂れば茂るほど
植物体の中の状態は暗くなります
それは葉は太陽の光が
当たるように茂っていくからです
ですから 私はこの乾電池で駆動する
無線でデータを計測できる
こういった物を開発することによって
植物の上と植物の中で
２ヶ所で計測することで
植物の明るさの違いというものを
計測できるのではないかと考えました
これによって 同時に気温と湿度 明るさ
そう言ったものを計測できるのですが
蒸散の量 光合成の量というものを
葉っぱの「繁茂度」と言われる茂り具合から
想像することが
できるのではないかと考えています
一方 もう１つ重要になる
植物の吸収する水と養分です
こちらも水耕栽培の植物に限れば
給液タンクの中の水の量を計測すれば
どれだけの量の水を
植物が吸収しているのか
想像することができるかも知れません
そして その給液タンクの中の
水の養液の濃度を計測すれば
どれだけの濃度の養分が
水と一緒に吸収されたのか
こちらも間接的に計算することが
できるかも知れません
我々は このようなセンサを
多数開発することによって
同時に多数の気温 湿度 明るさ
そして水位 養液濃度というものを
計測できる環境を構築しました
そして 実際に それらのデータと
研究室で事前に計測しておいた
そのデータ系列との組み合わせで分かる
実際の植物の養分吸収量
というものの紐づけを行い
コンピュータに大量の
データの学習を行っています
そして 現在の気温や湿度
水位 濃度との状態から
これまでの過去のデータから
もっともらしい養分の吸収量というものを
コンピュータに推測させることはできないか
という課題にチャレンジしています
これによって 「篤農家」と呼ばれる
農業のプロフェッショナルが
経験や勘で実現しているノウハウを
コンピュータに再現させることができないか
そういうプロジェクトです
ただ ここで１つ気になることがあります
それは コンピュータに学習させるべく
経験値とも呼べる学習データ量は
多ければ多いほど 良いのであろうか
ということです
多ければ多いほど それを収集するための
労力が 時間が 大変になります
そこで我々はアメダスの
オープンデータを用いて
コンピュータに学習させるデータの量が―
３年分のデータを利用して そのデータと
コンピュータの予測するデータの誤差が
日本の気候は
縦に長いということもあり
札幌 東京 浜松 那覇といった
４地域を代表にとって
学習するデータの量を
最大３年分増加させることで
誤差がどのように変化するのか
という分析を行いました
ここで興味深いのは
那覇に関しては
学習データが多ければ多いほど
誤差というものが
小さくなったにも拘らず
札幌や東京 浜松といったエリアでは
特に札幌では 学習させればさせるだけ
良くなるということもなく
実は８ヶ月位データを学習させる位が
一番精度が良かったと言う
そういう結果が分かりました
つまり ここで言えるのは
コンピュータに学習させるデータ量には
適切な量というものがあるのではないか
そういう仮説を立てました
しかし 人間が それぞれの地域のデータを
コンピュータに学習させ
どれ位のデータが
最もいいのかということを
いちいち確認していたのでは
切りがありません
そこで私は１つの方法を思いつきました
これはコンピュータが
大量のデータの中から
様々なデータを抽出し
その抽出したデータから
複数の異なる予測モデルを構築して
予測をし続けるというモデルになります
みなさん 明日の朝の７時半の気温が
何度になるか想像してみて下さい
たぶん人によって この想像の仕方は
変わって来ると思います
例えば ある人は 今は春なので
「春の明け方の温度は大体これ位かな」と
「春」という言葉をキーワードに
予測するかも知れません
また ある人は最近の朝の
温度データというものをベースに
「大体こういう風に推移しているんだったら
明日もこれ位の温度になるだろう」と
予測する人も居るかも知れません
また 理系で統計に長けた人が居ればですね
過去の状況を分析して
今と同じようなデータだけを抽出し
そのデータから明日の温度を
予測するということができれば
より正確な温度を
予測できるのではないかと
考える人もいるかも知れません
いずれにせよ明日の朝になれば
正解のデータが分かります
ですので その正解が分かった時点で
どのような学習モデルを使って予測したら
一番精度がいいのかが分かります
ですから そのモデルを使って
しばらく予測をし続けるというような
アルゴリズムになります
もし何日か経って その予測モデルで
誤差が大きく生じるような状況になったら
また同じような複数のモデルを
生成し予測し直すということを繰り返す
これをコンピュータが自動的に
実行できるような仕組みを考えました
私は このアルゴリズムに
“Sliding Window-based Support
Vector Regression (SW-SVR)”という
名前を付けました
今日は折角 この場に
みなさん集まって頂きましたから
Sliding Window-based
Support Vector Regressionという
名前だけは覚えて
帰って頂ければと思います
（笑）
そして 私どもは磐田にある
静岡県の農林技術研究所で
実証実験を進めています
実際に こちらの無線散乱光センサを用いて
環境情報を収集し
大量の環境情報から
先程のSW-SVRを用いて
植物の窒素吸収量― ６時間後に窒素を
どれ位吸収しているのかということを
コンピュータに予測させています
そしてこの予測結果に基づく
窒素供給制御をすることによって
過不足のない給液制御を
実現しています
なぜ過不足のない給液制御が
重要かと言いますと
トマトのような栽培の場合
溶液を投入すれば果実の肥大化速度
というものは促進されます
しかし皮の成長よりも果実の
促進速度の方が速くなってしまうと
皮が割れてしまい
売り物にならなくなってしまいます
ですから多すぎてもいけない
少なすぎてもいけない
過不足のない給液制御というものが
重要になってきます
これが この冬に行われた
実証実験の結果のグラフの１つです
黒いグラフは 実際に植物が吸収したと
思われる窒素吸収量を表しています
赤いグラフは 我々のアルゴリズムで
植物が これだけ吸収するだろうと
予測された値になります
11月26日 最初に構築した予測モデルで
黒いグラフと赤いグラフは
大体同じ位の所を推移しています
しかし しばらく時間が経つにつれて
黒と赤い線は大きくズレが生じて来ています
そして 12月20日頃コンピュータが
自動的に再構築をする必要があると判断し
モデルの再構築を行いました
その後は 植物の吸収している量と
予測制御の量は大体同じ位の値を推移して
制御することができるようになっています
この結果から言えることは
コンピュータが人間のノウハウを
ある意味 再現可能になりつつある
という事実を示していると言えます
最初に私は 超高齢化社会を迎えることを
悲観的に考えるべきではないと言いました
現在 我々が取り組んでいるような
過酷な現場のネットワーク化
ノウハウの再現の可能性
これらを情報通信技術を駆使して
様々な産業や人を連携した
総産業化ということを実現できる
可能性があると考えています
発想は素人でしたが 玄人的に
実行することができれば
みなさんと一緒に明るい未来を
創成できるのではないか
そのように私は考えています
是非みなさんと明るい未来を
創成して行ければと思っています
今日はどうもありがとうございました
（拍手）